[Music]
from sexy to sophisticated the 2018
Billboard Music Awards served up some
seriously fierce looks are you ready for
making her first red carpet appearance
in two years Taylor Swift dazzled in
this pale colored gown by Atelier
Versace a high slit and feather
embellishments made it the perfect dress
for her red-carpet return the host of
the evening Kelly Clarkson showed off
her physique in a form-fitting black
creation that belt cinching her waist in
all the right places Christina Aguilera
also went dark and dramatic her train
making quite a statement Janet Jackson
this year's icon Award recipient went
for a unique casual fancy combo t-shirt
and belts and a full tulle skirt also
unique Kesha who channeled her inner
Coachella Queen long locks a wide
brimmed hat fringe and boots when it
comes to red carpet sexy style the stars
did not hold back
Demi Lovato Meowth in cheetah print
while Jennifer Lopez opted for crocodile
Alyson Stoner left her shirt at home and
Normandy Corday showed off some major
skin
[Music]
[Applause]